biology has been effectively eliminated
from american universities colleges are
teaching students that the subject is
subjective which means not real
there's no absolute if someone
identifies as a woman that person is a
woman
that person says his or her pronoun is
they or z
you got to call them they or z and if
you disagree
if you believe in biology if you have
some attachment to english grammar you
are punished
and that's what happened to nicholas
merriweather he's professor at shawnee
state university in ohio and the school
reprimanded him in 2016
to referring to a student as mr instead
of miss
administrators also forced maritha to
use made up pronouns like
z and xe we're not sure how to pronounce
that or tur
he was told to avoid gendered terms like
mother and father
well like a lot of people in this
country nicholas merriweather was
bullied by lunatics but he rarely
decided to fight back he filed a first
amendment lawsuit and he just
won his case in the sixth circuit court
of appeals
we're happy to have nicholas mayor with
her join us tonight along with kristen
wagoner who's the senior legal counsel
at alliance defending freedom
thank you both so much for coming on um
so first first to you professor that's
um it's amazing that you won i never
think of people
as fighting back against this what made
you decide
to take them to court
well basically if i had not i would have
been fired i would have been terminated
that was one reason
it wasn't the only reason the other
reason was as you say
as it just said i think we need to stand
up against it
and i did i do think that we are losing
our academic freedom we're losing
our freedom to disagree and unless and
until people stand up to it i think it's
just going to get much much worse much
much faster
kristen tell us what the legal
what the the the legal precedent that
you've set
in this case is that others can use to
win
well we won on both free speech and free
exercise grounds and the sixth circuit
court of appeals said very clearly
that the use of titles and pronouns is a
part of a debate that this nation is
engaging in right now and that those
terms are infused with great meaning
that it's not the government's role to
set the terms of that debate or to weigh
in on one side
or the other in fact the court's
decision actually referenced what would
happen
if the government demanded ideological
purity
it used examples like the government
could then force a pacifist for example
to have to support war it could force a
civil rights icon to criticize the
freedom riders
or it could even force a christian to
deny the existence of god
those are examples that the sixth
circuit itself recognized
and it basically said if the government
has that kind of power
it can essentially do almost anything it
wants that power is unlimited
well the to the truth always the truth
always does have i just can't
tell you how pleased i am to hear this
and how grateful i am to both of you for
fighting it thank you
i think you did all the service
congratulations